you want science to be based on
scientific facts and that's what I like
about the theoretical computer science
community is that they have
well-established long-standing open
problems and if you do make progress on
those problems and people will listen to
you rightfully because it means that you
have some new techniques some things
that people before couldn't do you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen Hughes Inga dr. Sebastian
Bou Beck is a mathematician and a senior
researcher in the machine learning and
optimization group at Microsoft Research
he's also a self-proclaimed bandit who
claims that despite all the buzz around
AI it's still a science in its infancy
that's why he's devoted his career to
advancing the mathematical foundations
behind the machine learning algorithms
behind AI today dr. doback explains the
difficulty of the multi-armed bandit
problem in the context of a parameter
and data rich online world he also
discusses a host of topics from
randomness and convex optimization to
metrical task systems and login
competitiveness to the surprising
connection between Gaussian kernels and
what he calls some of the most beautiful
objects in mathematics that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
sebastien gubeck welcome to the podcast
thank you you're a senior researcher in
the newly minted or relatively newly
minted machine learning an optimization
group at MSR which used to be called the
theory group and now there's a couple of
subgroups under this new umbrella so
give us a quick picture of the org chart
and who does what and then tell us how
we could best frame the work you do what
gets you up in the morning sure so I
will start with the new organization
that we have here at Microsoft Research
in Redmond so I guess a little bit more
than a year ago we started a new lab
which is called Microsoft Research AI
for artificial intelligence so this is
following of course all the hype and the
real scientific excitement around
machine learning so we created Microsoft
Research AI and some of the members of
the former Siri group decided to join
this new endeavor and that's when we
decided to create the machine learning
and optimization group and then the
other half of the group went to do the
algorithms group in just the basic
Microsoft research lab in Redmond so is
that actually a group the algorithms
group there is a group called the
algorithms group so of course in machine
learning and optimization we also do a
lot of algorithms in fact it is the main
focus of our group but specifically
around machine learning so you're in the
machine learning and optimization side
of this group yes and you also work on
algorithms but what gets you
particularly up in the morning what
questions are you asking what problems
are you solving so I guess in general I
am really passionate about online
decision making or decision making in
general I think no matter what you think
will happen in the future humans or
robots or AIS it will always be a need
for making decisions and the questions
of mathematics that surround decision
making I find them really fascinating
and they are still in their infancy so
there is really a lot to be done there
and somehow traditionally pure
mathematicians have not looked at those
questions so much and sorry there is
really this gap between beautiful
mathematics that has been developed
for physics or slightly more recently
for computer science but I would argue
that decision-making on line
decision-making is just as important
today as those more traditional topics
how does your group doing very
theoretical work on the math of machine
learning interact with other groups at
Microsoft Research or even the
discipline writ large right so you know
these days in the media we hear a lot
about artificial intelligence as much as
we would want to have it an artificial
intelligence that you know make
recommendation that tells us what we
should cook for the next day you know
help us sleep better whatever it doesn't
exist yet and what this means is that we
are still very much working on the
foundations so we have a couple of
techniques that do work great
including gradient descent convolutional
neural networks things like that they
really do work very well and naturally
big companies are investing a lot in
those and trying to you know engineer
around them as much as possible get the
full stack at the hardware ready you
know all of those things but there are
many many other things that we would
want to do that are out of reach for the
current techniques so what we really
need to do is to develop fundamentally
new tools and that's what our group is
doing well we couldn't talk about the
mathematics of machine learning and
sequential decision making without
talking about the multi-armed bandit
problem it's known as you say to be
simple I'm making air quotes here and
yet incredibly rich so explain this
essential problem and tell us what's new
in the research right now right so the
military program is actually the first
real research problem that I looked at
now a little bit more than a decade ago
so it's a mathematical question that
conceptualize the problem of exploration
versus exploitation so you know in our
everyday life we have to deal with this
problem you know do we order from the
same restaurants that we know we love or
do we try this new restaurant that we
don't really know yet whether it's good
or not so maybe I should explain where
does the name come from that's a good
idea
yeah so so in ameri
slang a one-armed bandit is just a slot
machine at a casino and you can imagine
that in the medium bandit you're facing
you know many of those one-armed bandit
and for every coin that you have you
have to choose which bandit you're going
to put your coin in and you know pull
the arm so we refer to the different
actions as different arms of the bandit
okay so that's where the name come from
and really got popularized in the 1950s
by Herbert Robbins and at the time it's
actually quite interesting the
multi-armed bandit problem was viewed as
a negative result in the sense that in
the 1930s people developed classical
statistics so people like Fisher or
Nieman and etc so they developed
classical statistics and then they
wanted very naturally to move to online
statistics so what happened if the data
is not given to you all at once but it's
coming to you sequentially and then they
realize that the question we're really
tricky really difficult and then Robbins
came along and said look at this
multi-armed bandit problem it's so
simple yet we have no idea how to solve
it so it was more viewed as a negative
problem but then what happened is that
in the early 2000 a huge a very
important application appeared on the
scene which is ad placement on the
Internet so a placement on the Internet
is exactly a bandit problem you can
imagine each user coming to your website
as you know one time step of your
problem and then for that user you have
to select which ad to present so each ad
is an arm of your bandit and then when
you present the ad you see whether the
person clicks on that you see whether
the treatment was efficient or not and
then you move on to the next one so it's
a new important application of Mohammed
so now what has happened since a hundred
years ago so what has happened is that
now we really care about applications
where as the number of actions the
number of arms is huge it's very very
large another application in fact is
website display so you can imagine that
you have many different way to display
your website and you know users are
going to prefer certain ways but this is
a combinatorial problem you know whether
you place the ad at the top or at the
bottom of the page whether you use the
color green of the color red so you have
many many possible choices which leads
to a community really explosion
of possibilities and in turn this means
that you have to really think very
deeply on how to leverage the experience
that you had with a certain arm to other
arms you have to understand what are the
correlations between those different
arms so this is what modern medium
Bandits is about
[Music]
let's talk about a project you're
involved in on the foundations of
optimization so optimization methods are
as you call them the engine of machine
learning algorithms give us an overview
of the research directions in this arena
particularly convex optimization and
explain why they're important to the
theory behind machine learning
algorithms
so today's optimization program in
machine learning are really
characterized by two key features one of
them is that they deal with optimization
problem in very high dimension so by
that what I mean is the number of
parameters of your model these are the
number of variables that you're going to
do optimization over we are not talking
about optimizing a single parameter in
dimension 1 or you know 2 or 3 parameter
in dimension 2 ostridge that are easy to
visualize for humans we're talking about
minions tens of millions probably
billions in the future that the space
we're dealing with in optimization today
so that's one of the big obstacle the
other one is just the sheer amount of
data so the data is so huge that you
have to be very careful about the
operation that you do with them you
cannot you know visit your whole data
set a million times it's just not
possible you have to do that more
parsimoniously so this begs the question
in turn when you go back to the
optimization literature on how to make
the most of the calculation that you
have already done and what are the basic
calculations that you can do to optimize
a function well the basic thing you can
do is to calculate its derivative its
gradient and now you're asking the
question given that the gradients that
you have observed so far how to best
combine them to calculate the next
gradient so this optimal usage of your
information it has a very long history
in optimization in particular in the
russian school and they developed
optimal methods in the 70s and the 80s
and we are only now starting to really
understand the fundamental concept
behind it really yes so it's actually a
quite interesting story at the end of
the 70s
Arkadiy nemirovsky with the leading
figure in the russian schooling
optimization
discovered that when the function that
you're optimizing is smooth you can
actually do better than the simple
gradient descent technique you can
leverage the past information in a
better way so we designed an accelerated
technique which later Yuri Nazarov who
is now a legendary figure in machine
learning simply fly dramatically and he
made a very practical algorithm out of
it which is not called Nesterov momentum
technique so this momentum technique was
first designed in the context of convex
optimization as a way to obtain an
optimal method and nowaday it's one of
the most practical technique for
training deep neural networks which are
non convex functions and you know we
don't really understand why momentum is
working there but that's the story of
that technique so there are things you
do that you don't totally understand but
they're working so you keep doing it
that's right but what our group is
actually doing is trying to understand
why they are working so in particular
for this momentum technique we worked a
lot on it and a couple of years ago with
my good collaborator in that Lee who is
now an assistant professor at the
University of Washington we found a way
to understand the momentum from a
geometric perspective and this is very
useful because when you start to be able
to draw a picture you get better
intuition so this was at least for us a
very important step towards
understanding better momentum you have
two big areas of interest well you have
a lot of areas of interest let's be
honest but you've noted that two big
areas of your interest are the interplay
between convexity and randomness and
optimization and also inference problems
on random graphs so I wonder if you
could just unpack those a little bit why
are you interested in them what do they
address why are they important enough
for someone with a brain like yours to
tackle so as I said before nowadays we
really deal with very high dimensional
spaces and one key technique to explore
those high dimensional spaces is to use
randomness and in classical convex
optimization randomness was not really a
tool that people were looking at they
were more focused on trying to
understand what can you do with the
mystic methods so it seems to me that
there was and their cities to some
extent a real opportunity to bring in
those randomized algorithm tools into
convex optimization and hopefully get a
couple of breakthroughs on the way so
that was for the first area the second
area actually was one of my areas of
focus for a couple of years which comes
from the observation that nowadays many
data set come in the form of a graph and
what you want to do is you want to do
basic statistics with it what are you
know the basic things that you want to
compute with those graphs to my surprise
there were some questions that seemed
really fundamental to me that were not
looked at so there are a couple of
models which are very well known now in
random graph theory and in network
analysis to explain say how the facebook
graph grew or you know how the Twitter
graph is growing and one basic question
that I wondered about is okay so you
have those evolution processes but they
start with some seed graph so the seed
is not empty it's not like you know
Facebook started with one user it was
actually seeded with hundreds of users
so maybe more so what I was curious
about is that there was this discrepancy
between the reality where people were
designing very carefully a good seed
graph in order to enhance the growth of
the network and the mathematical
analysis which was thinking about what
if the seed is empty so the first
question that I asked was is a theory
without a seed relevant to the practice
with a seed and what we proved is that
it's not that you know if you have two
different seeds you can get two
completely different graph evolution
processes cancel please yeah we didn't
expect it we thought that maybe you know
in the very large sample regime at the
end of time once everything has settled
down then maybe the C that doesn't
matter anymore but that's not the case
interesting you have a blog called I'm a
bandit and it deals with random topics
in optimization probability and
statistics that's right
so first of all I'm glad you're not
knocking over Bank
but the big topic here is bandit convex
optimization talk about this in general
and then talk about your polynomial time
algorithm for bandit convex optimization
will go kind of deep here I'd like you
to get as technical as you like but also
will nod to the fact that you've got a
great video on this on the website and
three big blog posts on it that kind of
goes deep into the weeds yeah yes so
bandit convex optimization is a
following poem so as I said before the
new research on the museum bandit
program is really interested in the case
where there are many many actions so now
you can ask okay what about the limit
case where there is actually an infinite
number of actions a continuum of actions
so then of course if you don't make any
assumption about how the rewards are
shaped over this set of actions there is
no hope you cannot hope to find you know
what is the best action but as we
discussed already one of the very basic
assumption which has found a lot of
application in machine learning is
convexity so then the question becomes
in these Bandit scenarios where you have
a continuum of actions and the loss
function is shaped as a convex function
what can you do
can you still recover the optimal
guarantees that we had before with just
two or three actions so this was an open
problem that was published in 2004 and
when I joined Microsoft Research five
years ago the Seri group and some of the
members in the Seri group in particular
offered a curl with now the manager of
the machine learning and optimization
group and new Val Paris with a
distinguished probably list they were
talking and thinking about this problem
and when I joined you know I was coming
with my own expertise on bandits and I
was really excited to join the group and
then start thinking about the question
that those guys cared about yeah and we
were very fortunate that we made good
progress on it so our first stride into
the problem was in fact to show
something a little bit unique in machine
learning which was we showed that the
problem is solvable but we didn't
actually give a technique to solve it so
that was both interesting and
disappointing
that don't make no sense yes it was
strange we were all surprised by this
result to some extent but also very
excited because it meant that there is
something to be discovered there the
problem is solvable but it is certainly
not solvable with the current techniques
that we have drill in there for a second
because you're actually saying something
that baffles me you could solve it but
you don't know how you solved it so it's
more as follows there was this very
concrete question can you get square
root II regret for bended convex
optimization what we showed is that the
answer to this question is yes yes it is
in principle possible to get scrotie
regret for bending convex optimization
but we did not give an algorithm that
actually achieves this regret guarantee
so then the question remained can you
actually get a polynomial time algorithm
like an efficient algorithm something
that will actually work on real data and
that get this quality type behavior so
that was a state of this problem when in
that Lee came from an internship with me
in the summer 2016 and we started
thinking about this question and again
we were lucky to come up with a new
approach based on kernels so kernel
methods are are long and distinguished
history in machine learning in fact they
were the most popular technique before
deep learning overtook the field and
what we found is a connection between
Bandits type information and kernels
that there is really an interplay
between the two and while we were
exploring this to our own performance we
discovered that there is a connection
between kernels and what are called
Bernoulli convolution so Bernoulli
convolutions they are a mathematical
object that were defined in the 1930s
that Paulie adores the famous
mathematician sort of as one of the most
beautiful object in mathematics and this
Bernoulli convolutions they are directly
related to the Gaussian kernel in
machine learning
and there are exactly what we need the
to solve bandit convex optimization and
it turned out that the word expert on
this topic was you know my officemate
sitting next door Yuval paris so it was
very convenient that I could go to him
and ask him all the questions around
this and then later Ronin Alden joining
us on this project who was also one of
the member of the team with which we
prove that there is a solution but we
don't know what is a solution I just had
the biggest grin on my face I every
podcast I hear things that delight me
and nobody can see my face
[Music]
let's talk about tasks systems as a
level set tell us what they are and what
they're for and then talk about metrical
tasks systems and how they're different
so we have discussed so far the
multi-armed bandit problem which is a
very fundamental and important problem
but it's missing a notion of a state so
in most of the real-life problems that
we care about it's not like you take an
action and it has no consequences in the
future in fact when you take action
often the state of the world or the
state of the system that you're acting
on is evolving and you have to take that
into account so task system are a very
fundamental mathematical model ization
of this problem and it goes like this
so in task system you have a finite
state space I'm going to say that n is
the size of the state space and you're
again going to play a sequential game
just like in multi amended and at every
time step what you presented with is a
task and what is a task a task is a cost
function on the state space so a task
just tells you for every state how long
it's going to take you to complete the
task if you're sitting in that state so
now in the game you're sitting in a
certain state you know because of what
you have done in the past you see the
new task coming at you and the question
is to which new state do you move to
complete the task
now of course stated like this you would
just move to the state that has the
minimal completion time for the task but
that's where the metrical path comes
into play symmetrical task system so the
metrical part is that states they can be
far away from each other it's not like
you can easily move you know from a
state where say you know no mathematics
to a state where you're world expert in
mathematics this is going to cost you a
lot to make this movement you know to
change your own state so now you can
think of the state space as a metric
space meaning that there is a notion of
distance between two states and when
you're sitting in a certain state and
you get your new task when you move to a
new state you're going to pace the
distance to travel there plus the
completion time
so this metrical test system were
introduced in the 80s in the theoretical
computer science community
and as I define it it's a very discrete
problem and as expected
people used discrete mathematics
technique to try to solve this problem
so the big conjecture is a big open
programming that subfield is the
following
so you say that an algorithm for
symmetrical test system problem is
competitive if it has the following
property no matter what the test
sequence is the algorithms performance
the total cost of the algorithm is going
to be comparable to the best it could
have done had it known in hindsight what
was the sequence of tasks to be
presented that's what it means to be
competitive it's basically means you can
see into the future so we're going to
say that your alpha competitive if not
only your comparable to the best you
could have done but you are at most
paying alpha times what the best could
have been so you know maybe you want to
be too competitive or three competitive
and the conjecture in that field is that
you can be login competitive for any
magical test system so we're not very
far from proving this conjecture we are
basically a polynomial factor off but
the important thing is that people we're
really looking at this problem from a
discrete mathematics perspective and
what we brought in a year ago with my
great collaborators Michael Cohen in
that Lee and James Lee is that we looked
at it from a convex optimization
perspective so we view this very
discrete problem in continuous space and
continuous time and once you make that
modification then it's very natural to
again talk about gradient descent and in
fact this auto strategy which is called
mirror descent and using this new
continued strategy we were able to
refine the guarantees that we know about
this problem so this was for the
discrete metrical test system and now
there is a convex version of the
metrical test system because just as for
discrete Milty unbanded you know there
is a lot of interest into going into the
case where there is a huge set of action
set of arms it's the same thing for
metrical test system you might be
interested in a case where the set of
states is in fact infinite so then if n
is infinity you know log n is also
infinity and you're not competitive
there's a question yes indeed this is
very disappointing and so the question
is just in metrical task system when you
task us our convex function over the
state space can you be competitive at
all
so this was an open program from the
early 90s from lineal and friedman and
what they proved is that in dimension 2
you can be competitive very restrictive
I mean certainly not talking about the
millions of dimension that we opened
with and what we just proved recently we
just put out the paper a month ago we
prove that indeed you can be competitive
for convex metrical test system in any
dimension but the competitive ratio that
you get is going to depend on the
dimension and a great open question is
whether you can get polynomial in the
dimension scaling that seems very
difficult all the rest of it seems very
difficult also and this then as you
reference all 30 year old problem right
so in this literature they don't talk
about convex metrical pass system
instead they talk about these problems
that they call chasing convex bodies so
in chasing convex bodies you are moving
a point in Euclidean space so let's say
you're moving a point with G parameters
and every time step you're given a
convex set of constraint and what you
have to do is you have to move your set
of parameters inside this convex set so
you have to chase the convex set you
have to go inside the convex set and you
see the sequence of convex sets that are
given to you and you keep moving and
then again you want to be competitive so
you want to compare yourself to the best
you could have done in hindsight had you
known the sequence of convex bodies
right from the start and so indeed we do
show that you can be competitive to
chase convex bodies
so going philosophical a little bit here
we talked about some of the issues with
what we call the current machine
learning culture versus the culture of
theoretical computer science which is
more traditional what are some of the
things we ought to be paying attention
to right now is there anything that
keeps you up at night anything we ought
to be thinking about yeah sure so I
personally believe that science is a
fundamentally slow enterprise it takes
time to digest new concept it takes time
to really recognize whether something
that looks new on the face of it is
actually new or it's just you know a
slightly different point of view a
slightly different perspective our time
is a little bit different from you know
say two decades ago and one reason is
just because the amount of data that we
have so we have this influx of data and
people want to do something with it so
this I believe is not going away now and
there will be a need for you know data
scientists and people who really think
deeply about how to use and how to
leverage information that you can
acquire from data so that will not
change what I worry a little bit more
about is the culture which is centered
around claims which have no as far as I
can tell no mathematical basis you want
science to be based on scientific facts
and that's what I like about the
theoretical computer science community
is that they have well-established
long-standing open problems and if you
do make progress on those problems and
people will listen to you rightfully
because it means that you have some new
techniques some things that people
before couldn't do so there are pros and
cons force is very well defined open
problems the cons is of course that
those open problems they are not solving
burning practical questions that we need
to resolve right now so then you know
you come up with a solution and it's not
like people are going to implement your
algorithm right away so these are maybe
not the most important question if you
really want to get new algorithm right
away but on the other end progress on
this question this is deep progress this
is progress where you really develop new
tools which hopefully maybe a couple of
years from now some more practice
methods are gonna emerge out of it tell
us a bit about your history academic and
otherwise it's always great to hear
personal anecdotes about where people
came from and how they ended up where
they are what's your story
sure so I grew up in a small town around
Strasburg in France next to Germany
what's it called its called Obama's
bagging which means the house at the
bottom of the hill and then you know
there is a city next to it which is
mittelos bagging the house on the middle
of the hill and then there is neither
house back in the house at the top of
the hill so these are the three towns
where you know I was hanging out until I
was 18 so during those first 18 years
yeah I didn't know anything about
mathematics science but then at 18 I
went into this thing which is called
Peppa so that's famous in France that's
where you train to go into the Gandhi
Khel Engineering groans I call or you
know II call not much barrier which is
where I went where you learn how to do
mathematics so that's where I really
fell in love with mathematics I will
always remember it like the very first
lecture I immediately thought okay this
is the first time that somebody is
saying that something that really
resonates with me so two years of trêpa
one year in a corner multi-payer and
then I moved on to do my PhD what I
thought at the time I wanted to do was
mathematics of the brain but then I
realized that there was no such thing
but as I as I realised that I also
noticed this field of machine learning
which seemed very exciting so I started
to learn no about it and then I decided
to do a PhD in machine learning and
specifically in the military ended
problem so that's what I did in France
so how did you end up at Microsoft
Research after my PhD I did one year in
Barcelona for my postdoc which was just
amazing scientifically and otherwise and
then with my wife we moved to Princeton
New Jersey where I was an assistant
professor in the art department I stayed
there for three years and then I did a
semester at the Symons Institute in
Berkeley
and that's where I met you well Paris
and that's also where I discovered the
field of theoretical computer science
which again I fell in love with and
that's really where I could see you know
my second coding let's say after
mathematics really say logical computer
science I thought the people in the
field were amazing I saw the questions
they were looking at we're fantastic I
thought their work ethic was very
refreshing so that's where I met you
well Paris and then after that is
history that's why I joined the
Microsoft research I came to visit and
they made me an offer and I decided to
join so as of two days ago you have a
pretty cool announcement to make
right so our paper joint work with
researchers in RIA in France and in that
lis again in tightly just got awarded
the best paper at nips so it's pretty
exciting tell us a little bit about the
paper and what it's adding to the
literature in the field right so it's in
fact tying back to one of my main area
of interest which is convexity and
randomness so the question we were
looking at is the problem of distributed
convex optimization so what happens when
the objective function that you want to
optimize which depends on your data it's
not all in a single place but the data
is distributed among many servers then
how do you optimize both the
communication between the different
servers as well as work that each server
is doing so that's the question we were
looking at of course we weren't very far
from being the first ones to look at
there are literally hundreds if not
thousands of paper written on this topic
but somewhat surprisingly it seems that
nobody has really looked at optimal
methods meaning provably optimal both
upper and lower bounds so in classical
serial optimization this is again work
done by the russian school academia
offski yuri Nesterov and those people
but I didn't look so much at the
distributed scenario and one reason I
think is because in these distributed
scenario in fact randomness is key
randomization is very very important and
that's what our paper proves is that if
you use randomization then you can get
optimal guarantees
that's awesome congratulations thank you
Sebastian
as we close I always ask my guests to
offer some parting advice to our
listeners whether it be in the form of
inspiration for future research or
challenges that remain to be solved and
your recent paper kind of teased that up
a little bit what would you say to
researchers who might be just getting
interested in this field may be a good
advice to any starting researcher is to
become an expert in a very narrow field
or even now a question but really become
the word expert in that question and
that will yield rewards for a very long
time so that's what I did with the
multi-armed bandit program and I think
this was very successful and you know
later on I could see connections with
this problem that I wouldn't have made
if I didn't know all of this about the
momentum now in terms of research
directions there are really many many
question emerging so one of them we
already mention is in this chasing
convex body problem we showed that you
can be competitive but our dependency on
the dimension is very bad it's
exponential in the dimension so a great
open question but difficult one is
whether you can be polynomial another
open question is this metrical test
system to actually solve the
long-standing conjecture or whether you
can be log and competitive this is a
fantastic question that relates to how
do you define a good notion of entropy
for general metric spaces it's really a
very deep and beautiful question we
don't know how to solve this related to
this latest best paper award at nips in
fact you can think about the multi
unbanded version of this problem which
is exactly distributed banded this
program is basically entirely open and I
believe it's a very rich question and in
fact it does into a broader question of
how do you think about multi-agent
problem hmm
and this is a very rich field yet to
emerge
Sebastian gubec thank you very much for
coming on the podcast it's been really
really interesting my pleasure
I really enjoyed the questions to learn
more about dr. Sebastian doback and how
theoretical computer scientists are
tackling the multi-armed bandit and
other combinatorial conundrums visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]